autre star entrepris vous allez le voir
jean paul belmondo a reçu ce matin le
prix du brigadier pour sa performance
d'acteur danthine qui naît à la fiche
depuis onze mois au théâtre marigny à
paris mais le mondo et ému car pour lui
c'est une grande première georges bigot
assistance des grands jours ce matin à
la mairie de paris pour la remise par
jacques chirac d'une bûche de noël bien
singulière à jean paul belmondo le prix
du brigadier décerné par un jury de
professionnels symbolisée par
l'instrument le brigadier qui sert à
frapper les trois coups l'émotion sans
doute jean paul le quintal envers
ce brigadier toute ma jeunesse m'a fait
peur quand j'entends des frappes et
j'avais l'estomac qui se nourrit mais
c'était une belle peur est bon
aujourd'hui gelée aussi parce que quand
on reçoit un prix faut remercier
évidemment il sait pas commode surtout
moi je n'ai pas l'habitude de recevoir
des prix ça fait 37 ans que je fais
l'acteur
28 ans que je suis quand l'appel d'une
vedette et c'est la première fois que je
reçois un peu jamais ces désespérés
pour entonner le petit scoop là l'année
prochaine
cyrano de bergerac robert hossein et la
commune française la gauche française ne
sais pas encore je parle avec mon ami a
le culot nous verrons mais en tout cas
serrano s'est créé sur